Two-way relationships.
Gosh!
That was worse than the last one.
Remember, data storage is cheap.
The user's time is not.
What else could go wrong?
What else could go wrong.
[MUSIC]
>> Corporate mandated
work time is now over.
Lunch time for
sectors 113, 114, and 115.
Please enjoy your lunch.
>> [SOUND] There's a protein
clump in my instarito.
I really can't eat this.
>> 9443, Walter, you have to keep up
your strength if you're going to keep
filing these tax returns.
You remember what happened to 1253?
>> Her name was.
But really, I wish our corporate
overlords Grocery Grabber LLC would
pay more attention to food quality.
You'd think they would, considering
they started as a food company.
I wonder what Shopping List++-
>> Quiet.
You must not speak the forbidden name.
9443, Walter, I know times are hard.
Sometimes I wish I could talk to JP.
But I haven't seen him since
he joined the resistance.
[MUSIC]
JP, what happened to you?
>> I've suffered a terrible injury
at the hands of the robot army that
controls our every move,
but it was worth it.
Do you remember back in the days when
Grocery Grabber was just a small company
competing with Shopping List++ instead
of the evil megacorporation that
runs our very lives?
>> Yes, and we shan't forget.
>> Well, back then, the evil programmers
at Grocery Grabber had discovered
a little-known rule in Firebase.
[COUGH] This rule could be added to
a Firebase security and rules document.
With this very rule, they could read
data more efficiently and faster.
Hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of lines of data.
It allowed them to eventually take over.
Here, let me pull up
an astral computer screen.
[SOUND]